racism is real and it can not only cause
psychological pain but also
physiological damage to those who
experience it so today we're gonna look
at the science of racism using studies
and evidence to see exactly how it
impacts individuals uncover what makes
people racist in the first place and
understand what we can do to
successfully combat it right now every
time a resume comes across somebody's
desk the name on it makes a difference
after sending out over 1300 fake resumes
and response to employment ads
scientists found that resumes with more
traditionally sounding black names
receive 50% fewer callbacks than those
with more white sounding names again
these resumes are literally identical
except for the names this shows how one
aspect of racism can have a significant
impact on opportunities now classism is
a huge issue studies show that if you
grow up in poverty you'll experience
more discrimination than people that are
wealthier than you
but even when black and white people
grow up in wealthy families and have
similar education even though they start
wealthy black boys are more likely to
end up poor one of the major factors can
start as early as preschool where
teachers are more likely to punish black
students over white students for the
same behavior even in adulthood prison
sentences for the same crime are 10%
longer for black men and the use of
force is 3.6 times higher when studying
the existence of racism towards
indigenous people in Australia 45% of
indigenous families reported racism and
interestingly scientists began to link
these experiences to poor mental health
status sleep difficulties obesity and
even asthma which brings up an important
fact racism can truly be damaging to
your health
now racism involves a set of people
holding power over other people and that
imbalance and power is what causes
stress and again this can be measured
experimentally
when Latina students were paired with
people they've been told have racial
bias against them that cardiovascular
stress response went up compared to
those who have partner with people they
told had no bias against them at all
another study of Korean immigrants found
the discrimination was linked to
debilitating mental health effects in a
scientific community is now validating
how racism plays a significant role in
the formation of health disparities so
much that they are now links to breast
cancer hypertension and heart disease
the chronic stress of racism can have
people leaning on negative health
behaviors like smoking and drinking in
fact the amount of racism that a person
experiences in a year is positively
correlated to the number of drinks and
cigarettes consumed of course you'd
expect that if you go to your doctor
your health would be in good hands but
racial biases exist here as well
hundreds of medical physicians were
asked to look over a case of either
black or white patients who likely just
suffered a heart attack those who scored
higher on a racial bias test were less
likely to prescribe black patients a
drug that would reduced blood clots and
prevent heart attacks in fact half of
white medical students and residents
still believe in false biological
differences between white and black
patients like that black patients are
more pain tolerant than white patients
because of less sensitive nerve endings
and thicker skin these false beliefs
negatively contribute to medical
treatment in doctors with these biases
don't outright refuse to care to black
patients and they probably don't
consider themselves a racist yet these
biases persist in society and in
institutions which means that many
people still hold these beliefs and
values for example studies show that
most people receive the faces of other
races to be more angry than faces of
their own race now these findings make
some people uncomfortable because it's
hard to look at your own bias and where
you sit and perpetuating some of these
values and beliefs that don't do the
good that we
we're doing now the good news is there's
a lot that we can do to combat racism
and unlearn our own biases right now the
thing is we're not born racist we learn
biases from our environment and how we
are raised when children are adopted
before the age of eight by someone of a
different race they actually develop the
same facial recognition patterns of
their adoptive parents rather than their
own race it shows that our ability to
quickly judge other races is learn from
our parents or our environment this is
why talking about racism and anti racism
is so important maybe do all racial bias
the important thing to know is that you
can change your brain a study of brain
scans showed that a specific brainwave
pattern occurred and those is racial
bias when they saw a face that they
perceived as threatening but immediately
after a brain wave from the rational
part of the brain the prefrontal cortex
came in and challenged at initial
brainwave our brains and the neurons
inside them are constantly rewiring this
means is you can literally retrain your
brain and combat racist thoughts and
here's an example of how a study found
racial bias lessened after subliminal
exposure to counter stereotypes
participants were shown faces of popular
celebrities of diverse races including
Beyonce and this kind of priming led to
decrease bias within seconds to minutes
this emphasizes the scientific
importance of representation in media
this might seem a little obvious but
people who spend more time with
different races and different
backgrounds show less bias this is
called contact theory where intergroup
contact reduces intergroup prejudice is
why something like segregation increases
racist behaviors and ideas and finally
ideas and even science flourishes when
diverse people work together a study
that analyzed the last names of 2.5
million research papers as a proxy for
ethnicity found that when authors work
with people of different races and
backgrounds their work received 10% more
citations and prestige these are
scientifically based studies that we use
examples of how to combat racism the
most important thing is to be aware
aware that racism exists aware that it
is damaging and aware that it is up to
you to combat it all together
you